the holiday season is over but the
hotels are still filling up this week
the home office has taken over a second
hotel in Torbay as it struggles to find
space for migrants from Albania Sudan
Iraq and elsewhere
council is considering taking legal
action it says a high percentage of
migrants are presenting themselves as
under 18 which is significantly
impacting its ability to help local
children we are working and our social
workers are working incredibly hard to
balance these risks but we are pushing
them to Breaking points so therefore as
a consequence we don't have these social
workers available to undertake their
normal safeguarding responsibilities
processing these migrants May cost
around a million pounds money that
strapped councils like Torbay simply
don't have
the home office says there are 37 000
Asylum seekers in UK hotels at a cost of
5.6 million pounds every day one of them
is Muhammad he arrived on a dinghy with
29 others at the start of August now
he's in painting and told Sky News he's
grateful to the locals
the people and the government they are
purified provide me or provide us the
protection
okay the people there help us every time
your plan is to
live here and then get your wife and
daughter over here for a better life yes
yes we we are safe here
but keeping Muhammad safe comes at a
cost the council here says it does want
to do its bit to help but it is having
to cancel essential services like social
worker visits and appointments those
staff are now being diverted elsewhere
to help the migrants
the home office told Sky News
accommodation needs were now at record
levels it added while we accept that
hotels do not provide a long-term
solution they do offer safe secure and
clean accommodation and we are working
hard with local authorities to find
appropriate accommodation during this
challenging time
these are the quiet months in the
English Riviera and while some hotels
May welcome a block booking from the
home office it may come at a cost for
local Services Dan Whited Sky News in
Torbay Devon